burger king is the latest company to get
really woke their new ad campaign
is not about how delicious their
hamburgers are the bigger the burger the
better the burger is bigger at burger
king no
they now the woke culture has gotten so
extreme
so absurd that their ad campaign is
about how they are
as a corporation reducing
bovine flatulence in the atmosphere
[Music]
methane every time they do
and that methane from the ring goes up
to
the atmosphere and pollutes our planet
warming
[Music]
[Music]
in here or is it just me so to change
their
missions burger king went on a mission
testing diets i would help reduce their
[Music]
farts
[Music]
[Music]
when i'm thinking of what to eat for
lunch or dinner
the image that i definitely don't want
in my mind
is cows passing gas that doesn't that's
not nice that doesn't sound good and by
the way presumably they're talking about
this new grass that they have
that's going to reduce the amount of
times that cows do that presumably then
that that that air is going to be
trapped inside the cows and it's going
to end up in our hamburgers which is
even more disgusting
that doesn't sound very good advertising
used to talk
talk about how great their product was
make it so much more attractive
and yet now everything has become so
politicized the personal
is the political everything i mean this
this was the this was the promise of the
rise of identity politics
that now we're all so obsessed with was
that when you're when you have a
separation between the public and the
private
the personal and the political that we
require in a democratic republic
then the conservatives are going to win
because we can have reason debate but
when you have identity politics
when you just talk when you talk about
the sun people and the ice people
you talk about how those people are less
than they're savage they're they're
like animals and we're like we're
civilized humans and that's it
based on our race when when you have
that then you're
you you're a much more reliable voting
bloc the personalized
everything's got to become political now
including cheap hamburgers
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software
for contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description